In the depths of luxury,
there lives a miracle called the Right
She says she uses mysterious arts There
is a tree that I asked for
Can you send that skylark to paradise
I waited for his soul to return
I wonder if I can call that person
Somehow,
courage seems to possess him
Poor bird can't go to the princess
Pooh is very fond of samurai
Lord Luffy Please,
that one  Please help
the skylark Are you talking about the queen
again?
If it's for Nyannyan, it's a cheap order
Someday it will
surely become a disaster for Tacha
[Music]
I have to live here, that's my destiny What does it
mean that love is the weapon and the emperor?
There's a secret I don't even know  Isn't it